[Music]
well i remember myself as young as
11 years old looking at myself in the
mirror trying to imagine there's a crowd
of people and i'm giving a speech
and reminding people to speak out for
their rights and then i was there at a
stage speaking at the
un speaking at the nobel peace prize
ceremony some people called me
the girl who was shot by the taliban
and some the girl who fought for her
rights
and today you know i just can't believe
that i have graduated from university i
have finished my
education i look at you and i go wow you
grew up when did that happen
look at you well that's my question as
well
let's talk about that graduating from
university because you graduated from
oxford university last year
you couldn't have your traditional
graduation ceremony
so how did you celebrate graduating from
college so just like everybody else i
took my exams at home
and then i graduated at home it was
tough
and then you have two younger brothers
and a family and everybody is annoying
you and they're coming to your room
malala i think this is funny you sound
like a lot of 20 somethings because now
you're back
you're still living at home you have
younger siblings you said and they
and people are annoying you oh hundred
percent they annoy me all the time
so i have two younger brothers and one
is like you know 21 the other one is 17
and sometimes you know there are
arguments but in the end you know
we resolve all those fights when you
have brothers at home
and you are their only sister and you
want to make sure that your brothers
learn about
women's rights and equality you have to
show that leadership in your house i
want to make sure that my brothers
respect
you know my values my rights and and my
opinion
and they need to treat me as a as a
human
for malala yousafzai those values are
the center of her work at malala fun
that's a non-profit she co-founded to
break down global barriers for
girls and their right to an education
we are every girl who wants to learn and
live in peace
and today she is announcing an exciting
new partnership
for her next chapter i'm very excited
for this next project that i'm starting
uh i will be uh producing with apple tv
plus
and i will be creating uh content that
includes comedy
and uh tv shows and uh and documentaries
and movies
and i am really excited for this part of
my journey because it will help me to
reach
young women and girls people that know
you very well say that you have a
tremendous sense of humor
i love comedy i'm a big fan of it i have
watched like tom and jerry and everybody
knows mr bean so there's a sense of
connectivity that
entertainment industry is bringing into
our lives you know recently when i was
watching this show
ted lasso on uh apple tv i love chad
lasso
he's incredible and he's like a really
funny guy i always figured the tea was
just gonna taste like hot brown water
and he constantly was reminding me of my
dad so
how did you decide that you would you
wanted to partner with apple
so i have met tim cook in person and i
know how passionate he is for
women's rights equality and education
and tim
like you know i have met so many people
who say nice things but don't follow up
but tim was just very different
he literally like started supporting
malala fund the admiration between these
two is mutual
apple ceo tim cook spoke with us about
his working relationship
with youssef psy over the years the
apple tv plus
for us is a platform for very
impactful and creative storytellers that
really want to connect with their
audience
and change the world in the process and
there's no better example of that than
malala
what was your first impression of her i
met malala
back in 2017. you know what i found was
someone wise beyond her years and
i was i was all in i wanted to work with
her
yeah you also traveled with her on the
road we went to beirut together
and i saw firsthand how the malala fund
was helping girls syrian refugees
and i saw how malala interacted with
them and inspired them and lifted them
up
it was one of the most moving meetings
of my life you and tim cook you seem to
have formed a very unique friendship
tim has been you know a mentor a
supporter
and i still can't believe like this is
happening hard work malala
does not seem to scare you since we know
you work hard
i would like to know how you play i
heard this tell me if this is true
that if you were stranded on a desert
island the soundtrack you would like to
bring is phantom of the opera
is that true yes phantom of the opera
i'm a big fan of
musicals uh you know hamilton to phantom
of the oprah and i hope that you know
when things get back to normal we can
have those experiences again
as you sit here before us today we all
met you through tragedy
i mean and it's because of your courage
really your courage and speaking out
that everybody knows your name malala
what goes through your mind when you
think about that little girl
to be honest when i think about that
little malala
i i get inspired she was very strong and
courageous
and sometimes i ask i still ask for her
help
she had a few values that i have still
carried with me things will not change
unless somebody
you know takes a step and makes that
change happen you once said this
you'll never know who stands with you if
you don't stand up first
and i like the message on that what is
your takeaway on this international
women's day
women must be really proud of themselves
they have worked so hard women globally
standing up for their rights
women are there not just talking about
women's equality but
they are participating in other
movements as well from climate change to
uh you know gun control and to all the
young girls out there
i will remind you believe in yourself
believe in your voice
and become the change makers of this
world the world needs you